[Música]
bom antes de mais nada gratidão por aqui
abrindo esse evento tão importante no
ano tão importante é antes de começar
qualquer coisa eu quero trazer umas
informações pra vocês
opa a gente está falando aqui agora de
um país onde tem muita gente focada em
mandar currículo e não necessariamente
achar uma outra alternativa
a gente está falando de pessoas que
trabalham mais projeto felicidade no
final de semana
a gente está falando também de um país
que fecha 95 empresas por dia
será que realmente o brasil tem uma
cultura empreendedora
será que a educação pelo menos nessa
área não falhou
se a gente for pensar em relação ao
conhecimento o conhecimento está aberto
né
então hoje cidadão dado de novembro só
no estado de são paulo na unidade na
cidade de são paulo tinha 95
possibilidades de aprendizado
relacionados a um mapa um tema
específico gratuitas online coletivas
individuais e as pessoas já se
apropriaram disso elas estão buscando
conhecimento né
seja por ferramentas online ou seja por
indicações pessoas já se apropriar desse
lugar do conhecimento está aberto
só que talvez elas não perceberam ainda
que o que importa hoje é saber o que
importa ao invés da gente virar uma
grande esposa e se sente cada vez mais
preciso de mais a gente saber o que
fazer com que a gente tem e quando a
gente fala isso a gente se questiona
será que a educação é conhecimento
técnico ou será que o que falta para as
pessoas realmente empreenderem não só o
negócio em primeiro é a vida não tem a
ver com o comportamento
a gente está falando de uma sociedade de
pessoas com características são cartas
das quais limitadoras que não vem
necessariamente delas vêm eventualmente
do sistema das referências sociais delas
e quando falo isso eu falo de um oásis
que vem de um sistema familiar árabe
como essência empreendedor aonde eu fui
fases do processo então imagina carga de
energia que já vêm aqui quase junto com
toda a minha centralidade e aí eu tinha
basicamente aquele perfil claro ad hoc
assis é sucessora você vai fazer
administração de empresas
só que será que é isso que eu queria
para minha vida
será que essa história da empresa da
minha família é deles é nossa
ou será que eu posso construir a minha
própria história e eu tive essa clareza
graças a duas bases que formam parte no
processo educacional eu tive a
oportunidade de estudar com a filha do
paulo freire que tinha montado uma
escola pequena em são paulo eu tive uma
base que foi incrível gente não via na
pista tá eu tive essa oportunidade foi
incrível para identificar como indivíduo
e meus pais como classe média com foco
meu filho precisa para o mercado de
trabalho não foram usados assim me
colocaram no ensino médio médio numa
escola para passar no vestibular e ali
eu vi com uma desgastante esse processo
como isso não tem nada a ver comigo e aí
quando eu vejo isso falamos não fica no
chão que depois vai ter que ter pelo
menos mais quatro anos disse eu falei
meu deus eu não vou agüentar isso não
quero para minha vida definitivamente e
eu tive a oportunidade de ter um insight
focar-se que não posso em vez de fazer
uma faculdade em paralelo ela empreende
meu próprio negócio e é basicamente eu
percebi que as coisas não se encaixa é
tão simples assim não tem como sair e
abrir uma empresa é 6 horas do dia 18
uma falta sobre mão de estudar de manhã
sei lá então não tinha uma flexibilidade
de horário existe uma distância muito
grande da teoria e da prática e outro
ponto é que não tem como escolher uma
coisa empreender é aprender economia é
aprender psicologia aprender marketing
não tem como segregar isso está dentro
de uma aula
daí eu percebi que cara talvez veja seu
caminho vai ter que ser diferente
sim eu vou assumir uma formação
empreendedora
quando falo isso parece bonito ainda
mais aqui no ted onu mas é difícil fazer
isso porque quando você faz isso tem um
julgamento social fala meu deus vocês
mas como assim
mas como a gente não vai ter uma segunda
faculdade eu me peguei neste momento é
tomar a decisão se lá como eu vou
falando as mesmas e se você for preso
a gente ri na gente mas é extremamente
delicado perceber que tem muita gente
que toma essa decisão também por um
critério tão pífio né
basicamente quando se empreende serão
larga celular o ensino mas se apropria
do aprendizado
não é então você precisa se nutre de
coisas específicas adaptadas ao seu dia
a dia as necessidades da realidade e eu
pude tive oportunidade de absorver
conhecimentos de todos os tipos que eram
adversários momento que eu estava
vivendo o meu nível de aprendizado foi
visceral eu aprendi coisas incríveis
direto da fonte não só com o lado
acadêmico mas muitas vezes com o lado de
quem estava fazendo
e aí eu decidi fazer o seguinte o
negócio tem que soma duas coisas que
acredito muito forte
a primeira delas é o design design é
significar e dar desculpa se eu do
significado do design pra mim é dar
significado da significado à
implementação e eu preciso fazer a
implementação de algo de uma idéia de um
processo baseado numa estratégia em algo
que tem um porquê e não vou criar um
negócio baseado em dinheiro eu vou criar
um negócio baseado em amor eu vou
resgatar para as empresas vão usar as
empresas para poder empreender junto com
elas uma ressignificação daquilo que as
pessoas estão querendo fazer quando
atravessa voto até da minha super
companheira minha vida que viveu tudo
isso comigo essa falta da celebração do
evento nosso chave estava celebrando
aqui dez anos de relação como sócio e
marido e mulher
nove anos de empresa e ela estava na
barriga com o nosso futuro filho
bernardo então é um evento assim a apsi
pra gente não só a gente sabe que ele
estava sentindo o caminho que a gente
passou para chegar nisso deu muito
trabalho que empreender para quem sabe
podem dar muito trabalho tem glamour
nenhum não empreenda por dinheiro
definitivamente a empresa no brasil você
tem que ter resiliência você tem um
campo de aprender o que é quebrar
financeiramente que não quebrar na alma
diz que superar desafios de entender
todas as dificuldades mas se nutre com
isso basicamente o passeio durante dez
anos da minha vida empreendendo outras
histórias de diferentes empreendedores
pelo brasil
a gente não sai às 6 horas para casa a
gente está vivendo algo que realmente
aquilo lá a vida
e quando eu falo eu não sou só eu a
gente pede um time né de pessoas sem
terno e gravata sem necessariamente o
leblon o linkedin atualizado pessoas que
querem fazer isso acontecer então
durante esse processo eu pude viver de
certa forma uma perspectiva diferente do
meu negócio
o desenho foi uma escola também
empreendedorismo na escola pra equipe
para os empreendedores que viveram isso
e que significaram a forma como estava
lidando com os negócios e quando mostrei
no meio tem uma figurinha pequenininha
quer dizer senhor bernardo que para quem
mexe com educação já se prepara que esse
tipo de gente que tá vendo aí gente que
não separa a família e trabalho a gente
que não faria um pai provedor e uma mãe
não tem essa distinção mais gente que
sabe que ensina é uma coisa que
aprendizado no tem gente que sabe que a
importância do aprender a partir da soma
do amor e também da dor né
são bernardo é algo que está vindo muito
forte não só dele mas a partir de muitas
crianças e quando estão empreendendo
esse negócio bate na minha porta um
grupo de educação precisando de ajuda
precisamos oxigenar querendo
ressignificar a forma como ele conduzia
o processo dele um grupo de educação que
ele tinha como cenário um grupo baseado
no aluno mais focado instituições
um grupo que precisava focar em
processos e não em aprendizado que as
métricas eram números grandes e não
transformação humana onde o lucro estava
muito maior é muito mais importante do
que meramente um propósito e que a
tecnologia servirá para vender matrícula
quando olho pra isso independente do
grupo isso é uma realidade não é de
muito grupo por aí que precisa de ajuda
que precisa de ajuda então tem muita
oportunidade para inovar dentro desses
grandes grupos
basicamente o que aconteceu nesse
processo foi que eu tive oportunidade de
entender e mergulhar em educação durante
quase dois anos da minha vida entendendo
toda a complexidade disso e de lá a
gente viu dois caminhos um caminho de
como eu mudo que tem e outro caminho
como de fato ressignifica que tem a
gente apresentou isso o executivo que
estava à frente do grupo ele basicamente
falou o seguinte
isso dá muito trabalho você está aqui na
minha fazenda que na colômbia eu vou
descrever o meu foco é outro
não tem como mudar uma estrutura só que
quando a gente tem essa pulguinha de
da gente é mais fácil falar que entregue
o trabalho só que não né
aí eu tinha uma oportunidade
definitivamente de ressignificar esse
processo de tirar essa idéia do papel e
quando falou eu basicamente o o processo
foi o seguinte eu precisava validar isso
mostrará se isso tem realmente algo se
tem valor de prova de um grupo de
pessoas tão íntima pelo grupo dos jovens
então ele fez uma pesquisa com 1.200
jovens pelo brasil todos eles envolvidos
empreendedorismo júnior desses jovens a
gente mapeou as necessidades ele foi
falar com mais 150 instituições que
tinham habilidades e conhecimentos
específicos para suprir essas
necessidades deles e de lá a gente
montou tudo todo esse plano em 45 dias
porque em janeiro seria um intervalo de
aula então seria muita gente podia criar
uma experiência imersiva pra que eles
vivenciem o aprendizado visceral
então a gente cria uma experiência 33
dias passando por seis cidades o rio de
janeiro é uma delas
onde essas pessoas esses dez
selecionados não por grana
mas por vontade viver uma experiência de
empreendedorismo na veia viveram algo
que assim só ele sabe o que eles viveram
violentados em palavras ea gente fez
isso não a gente não centralizar esse
processo a gente falar com as
instituições mais incríveis que conhecem
de coisas incríveis que abriram o código
delas e personalizaram algo não para um
milhão de pessoas como é feito hoje para
dez pessoas dez indivíduos únicos gente
que vibrou no processo e criou quase uma
trix da vida real para essas pessoas que
viveram ambiente feito pra eles sob
medida
as dez pessoas encheram representante
carioca marcelo saíram de lá imagina
totalmente transformadas e quando a
gente fala da transformação não é só
porque a gente acha que a gente recebeu
um abraço no final vou ficar isso aqui
foi incrível não quente metrô ficou todo
esse processo diz que o documentário
disso aí teve um nível de evolução
individual de cada um em relação ao
comportamento e técnica e acompanhou a
eles em relação a sair desse dessa bolha
e viver a realidade que não é tão fácil
né então quando a gente viu aquilo a
gente focar a justiça negócio incrível
na mão deu muito trabalho a gente não
recebeu conseguiu captar um patrocinador
a gente teve que gastar e investir tudo
isso do nosso bolso
mas aí a gente falou
para encher um negócio que é incrível a
partir de lá basicamente o que a gente
fez foi vamos criar uma empresa onde a
gente resgata dois princípios base tem
nada a ver com educação 4.050 é a base
da educação
nunca um negócio baseado em identificar
as necessidades específicas e gharyen
pau mas faz sentido para transformação
daquele indivíduo quando falou eu porque
eu quero honrar sempre gosto de honrarem
sistêmica então davi andré e bruno que
foram os meus sócios que acreditaram
nessa maluquice
então quando a empresa sair do papel ela
sai baseada no que eu preciso focar como
premissa na personalização não do aluno
que o aluno já é um voto é da pessoa do
indivíduo está lá dentro eu preciso
focar também centralizar esse processo
não é somente uma pessoa que vai ajudar
ele precisa identificar o que já tem de
coisa legal no mercado para de fato
adaptar para aquela necessidade e
terceiro ponto tem que ser viável
não adianta pensar o negócio que não
cabe na agenda dele eventualmente não
tenha dinheiro para vento para financiar
o processo no processo durante essa
esses dois anos de empresa de ativação
empresa a gente transforma história de
pessoas diferentes entre os quatro e os
quatro exemplos específicos aqui de
pessoas que basicamente viver um
processo de transformação não só no
brasil mas em outros lugares onde em
tempos enxutos não preciso esperar dois
anos para fazer formação de verão
aprendizado específicos que tiraram é o
lugar onde ela se encontrava no entanto
teve oportunidade através das pessoas
por exemplo acessar 60 tipos e áreas
diferentes de conhecimentos bem
específicas a conhecer entender e
educação em diferentes lugares que não
somente às vezes o que aprenderam na
sociedade mas quando estiver tudo isso
fala nossa incrível ea gente vê que o
mundo tá efetivamente descentralizado
nesse conhecimento que já está aberto já
está online
mas será que a educação está se
comportando dessa forma será que na hora
de escolher uma faculdade ou algum lugar
ea gente deposita e terceiriza todo esse
processo será quem está se apropriando
de tudo que a gente poderia fazer se a
gente poderá se disso
quando falo tudo isso é que a educação
tem que andar de mão dada com o negócio
separa essas duas coisas a gente tem um
super desafio no processo
como que eu vou pensar numa escala
baseada em transformação humana
quando vou focar em tecnologia para
qualificar esse processo e não só
colocar o cón
online pdf negócios educação tem que
estar de mão dada a agente independente
do seu lado da base da onde você veio a
gente precisa dialogar e conectar com
esses dois pontos
os próximos passos do meu negócio não
sei
será que agora com dificuldade porque de
fato a gente vê um negócio que é feito
para poucas pessoas
mas agora ele tem um mundão de gente
querendo se absorver se a idéia é abrir
o nosso código abre nossa metodologia
para qualquer pessoa sem poderá desfazer
sozinho
será que é preciso que significa as
corporações que no fundo a gente está
estudando para entrar em algum lugar
será que significa cultura daquele lugar
as pessoas vão receber unificar a forma
como elas estão estudando na verdade não
faço a mínima ideia mas é o que eu vou
resolver vamos procurar resolver nos
próximos anos da minha vida
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]